hello
welcome to franciscan university again
we have our first speaker uh uh gregory
sadler
and he's from marist college and his uh
topic is
the anselmian account of the grounding
of morality
professors thank you
so this is part of a a larger project
that i'm working on um i've been working
on longer than i
really ought to be for any one given
project
but you know how long things take i'm
writing a book on saint anselm's moral
theory and one of the uh things that i
really like about it is that
it's not his his approaches to things
are not so systematic as you know say
look at st thomas where you can
figure out where to look for for
treatments of things you have to kind of
pull things together from from all of
his texts that would probably you know
also be sort of a
a
downside here for many people as well so
um
the fact that it's it's not so easy to
find things so what i'm trying to do is
systematically reconstruct a whole moral
theory that you know can be compared
against other people because i think
that is there an anselm
and when this this topic came up i
thought well does anselm have anything
to say about that about the topic and
yeah he does um
when properly pushed and
so that's what what this is i cut it
down quite a bit so there may be
some incoherences
but we can we can address those i guess
in the q a
when we ask the question whether
morality must be grounded on god we want
to begin by distinguishing several
different ways in which this question
might be understood
the question might focus on whether god
whether or not god is the ultimate
source for moral goodness
values or standards
or might ask whether or not some kind of
divine revelation is required in order
for morality to be understood or worked
out
alternately this question could turn on
whether a person requires some practical
engagement with the divine in order to
live or even build and understand a
sufficiently moral life and one might
also be inquiring whether it is possible
for some minimal pared-down morality to
be developed without an explicit
reference to
or reliance upon god on the basis of
common human experience and rational
reflection
in this paper my plan is to approach and
examine each of these four questions
pretty briefly in turn but in a slightly
different order than i just presented
them talking about god is unavoidable
when you're when you're working on the
ansem so i begin with the issue of god
as the origin of moral value and
standards but then we shift to a vantage
point much more typical of modern
thought and sensibilities taking
anselm's god out of the picture so to
speak
once we've gotten from him what we want
to think through that is a natural prac
a natural human practical rationality
which we'll then try to understand in
light of anselm's own remarks
um the third and fourth part addressed
what anselm would see his shortcomings
of such a de-christianized naturalist
approach to morality in the third part
we look at what guidance and assistance
anselm thinks christianity provides to
human reason in developing a more
adequate morality and in the fourth we
look at the indispensable role anselm
accords to god to christianity
understood not only his belief or
practice but also as a community and his
experience in moral development practice
and theory
so
in one this is the first part in one
important sense
from anselm's perspective morality must
be grounded out god for in fact
everything in being even an imagination
of possibility is ultimately in some
manner grounded upon god ontologically
for anselm god is the origin of all
created being as well as the ultimate
source of whatever goodness truth
justice or wisdom beings possess
axiologically god also occupies and
embodies the highest degree of every
genuine value
which are in many cases the divine
attributes with respect to certain of
these attributes human participation
those values is dependent in more
personal ways
upon one's relation with god
now anselm
depicts god as the source of all being
to such degree that like other christian
thinkers even senses the need to account
for the problematic status of evil
injustice probation and nothingness
god is the supreme being through or from
whom all
all of the things that exist have their
being he creates all beings indeed the
totality of created beings ex nihilo and
god not only endows beings with their
being he says by sustaining them they
thrive and continue in their being
he is also the cause of all truth and
rightness of things in in beings and
some says
as he says in the the day costume just
as nothing but good comes from the
supreme good every good is from the
supreme good likewise nothing but being
comes from the supreme being and every
being is from the supreme being and so
since the supreme good is the supreme
being it follows that every good as a
being and every being is is good day
concordia adds every quality and every
action and whatsoever possesses being is
from from god from whom all justice and
no one injustice has being
the relationship between creator and
created being is so intimately rich and
extensive that beings exist in the
divine mind even before they possess
independent existence of their own as he
says in sayipsis
and after they have ceased to exist
ansel maintains created beings are most
true
most good
most just most what they actually are
and what they ought to be in the divine
mind for humans this presumably
encompasses not only uh shared nature
from all human beings but even an
individual's distinctive personhood
as scholars have noted anselm is
metaphysically a christian platonist he
endorses qualitative distinctions
between higher and lower degrees of
being placing god at the hierarchies
apex god is not only the highest being
however he is being itself from which
all other beings possess their being by
way of participation as well as through
causality in fact as dynamic unity of
the divine attributes god is the origin
and highest of as anselm says whatever
it is better to be than not to be
including supreme life
happiness beauty and eternity
for each of these god does not simply
have but rather is that attribute all
other beings possessing that good to
their determinant degree through
participation
several of these divine attributes are
of particular interest and arguably
interrelated when we're considering
matters of morality
specifically the attributes of goodness
truth justice and wisdom
now
given all this it should be obvious that
in one important sense for saint anselm
morality is unavoidably grounded on god
the very possibility of morality indeed
the very existence of created being and
therefore any goods
choices dispositions
any other notions along those lines
depends ultimately upon god
in addition anselm's moral theory with
its uncompromising emphasis upon justice
and the will seems to require some
reference to an orientation toward the
divine will which embodies justice and
wisdom in their fullest sense
so here's the second part then
even granting in the in the last
analysis anselm's moral theory will be
strictly speaking theocentric one might
wonder whether it might not be possible
to remove the christian god from the
scene
so to speak so as to translate central
categories and concepts of anselmian
moral theory into a much more
humanocentric naturalized morality given
certain things anselm says particularly
in his treatises one might envision this
prospect quite optimistically
he is not viewed for nothing as a
representative of rationalism by at
least some some of his commentators not
not the best ones i think but some think
he is
consider a few representative statements
by ansel
first in the monology and attributing
his method to the demands of his fellow
monks he sets himself the goal
that nothing be argued for by appealing
to scripture but rather each point be
asserted on the basis of its own
specific examination so that by
unsophisticated arguments and simple
disputation reasons necessity might by a
few words compel and the directness of
truth might clearly set things out
proslogium seemingly takes this project
further oriented entirely by its
unimaginable single argument which would
require none other for demonstrating
itself and which would alone
suffice to prove that god does exist
which okay that's about being that god
is the supreme being needing no other
good which every other thing needs in
order to be and to be well and then
here's a great catch-all
and whatever else we believe about the
divine substance
kurdish homo likewise examines its
topics by setting aside christian
revelation both in scripture and in the
very person of jesus christ in order to
argue by quote necessary lines of
reasoning that is as anselm says by
plain reason and truth
in his treatises anselm does introduce
and even explore passages from scripture
but it's rare at least in the treatises
to find him resting the entire weight of
an argument or an investigation on an
appeal to scriptural authority
if phoenix quadren's intellectum
describes the entire anselmion project
including his moral theory it ought to
be recalled this formula itself is not
scriptural
but rather the fruit of anselm's own
rational reflection on the implications
of the passage if you unless you believe
you will not understand
in fact the infrequent uses and so makes
of scripture typically fall into three
classes a passage might provide a
starting point for rational reflection
usually by raising some puzzle or
problem
it might supply a suggestion as as to
the way to better understand the matter
and process of being reasoned out or it
might provide a complementary and
confirming end point for what reason is
worked out independently
turning specifically to the treaties is
that that anselm explicitly describes as
pertaining to the study of sacred
scripture the de veritate de libertate
and de casu one would expect to find
more reference to scripture in than
these works they actually contain
discussion about god even angels and
devils focuses centrally in these
treatises but there's an equal focus on
seemingly more specifically human
matters the different modes of truth the
nature of justice or moral goodness the
relationship between rationality and
free will how weakness or failure of
will occurs the complex architecture of
the rational creature's will
the distinction between different modes
of goodness and evil as predation
in hanselm's works
all of these issues are framed within a
metaphysics and moral theory that is
theocentric his treatments are these
matters are motivated by deep and
lasting desires on the part of anselm
and his fellow monks to penetrate and
progress further into christian faith
life and community through the
application of human reason
but
would it not be possible for us in the
late modern present to de-christianize
hanson's moral theory
would not whatever anselm is attained in
moral theory by his use of reason now
stand independently of any entwining or
entanglements with christian theology
revelation or practice
if this were to be the case providing
that we accept anselm's moral theory as
an adequate one
then we can answer the question whether
morality need be grounded on god in in
the negative
consider one central concept in anselm's
moral theory that of justice justice is
the mode of distinctive goodness
specific to rational beings endowed with
freedom of will anselm works out a
satisfactory definition of justice and
the de veritate is rightness of will
maintained for its own sake for an
action a volition a person to be just
requires that the person will
what he or she ought to will it also
requires that he or she will this for
the right reason with the right
motivation ordering goods rightly in
relation to each other and this in turn
entails that such a person in that
process of willing actually wills to
maintain rightness of will
justice provides a coherent norm not
only for which actions ought to be done
and which not what goods ought to be
pursued which evils avoided
and not only for what motives the will
ought to endorse in which it ought to
reject but even one structuring the
reflexivity of the will itself its
capacity for self-determination
in day libertate we learn further that
when will lacks this fundamental
self-orientation of justice this occurs
because the person will some other
actual or parent good and compatible
with maintaining justice and the will
that is they mistakenly choose something
as more valuable than justice
the ansem also reveals a complexity to
the will making an initial distinction
between will as instruments and will his
use expanded later to include willa's
inclination
he also in de casu distinguishes between
two fundamental orientations of the will
the one always present is what he calls
the will to happiness directed towards
beneficial goods or you know the bona
komoda
the other not always present is the will
to justice directed towards justice
which includes but transcends proper
ordering of the other goods
so perhaps with concepts such as these
anselm has supplied us with all the
basic tools we need in order to develop
and follow a morality adequate to our
human needs nature and capacities
we would need only to flesh out more
specificity is admittedly underdeveloped
notions like what went on to will and
why went out to will
what the will was given to us to will
proper ordering and so on
but he's got an answer to that
fortunately we're endowed with another
faculty which possesses capacities to
determine these matters that is
rationality
reason is an instrument to the soul he
says allowing us to quote distinguish
the just from the non-just the true from
the non-true the good from the non-good
and the more good from the less good
moral judgment discernment of values
ordering of goods and practical
reasoning are central to proper function
and discernment or development of
rational free human beings
so couldn't these activities of human
reason
rightly informing the activities and
orientations of the will as anselm
depicts it be emancipated from the
theocentric framework within which he
locates them
and works them out and we can reframe
this
granting when it comes to lasting
progress in moral theory worked out by
christian thinkers originally
perhaps one needed to believe some
revealed truth which then spurred
intellectual efforts to develop and
deepen rational understanding
but once that understanding has been
secured and articulated does it not
become a proverbial eternal acquisition
you know a katama academy's herodotus's
term for humanity
if any advances in moral theory occurred
through rational reflection upon the
human condition of light of christian
teachings
can't those be understood incorporated
applied and lived out just as well by
the non-christian even completely
secular person as they can be by the
christian
anselm himself seems to suggest such
rationalist interpretation when as he's
discussing the justice a person ought to
cultivate the will he seems to equate
the quote law of god with the law of the
mind
and still more in counseling that when
we interpret scripture he says we ought
not to cling to the impropriety of
language concealing the truth
but rather to seek out the proper sense
of truth hidden under all meanings of
expression
so
on to the third part
four sets of issues arise or maybe more
than four
that's what i came up with when i was
thinking about this for the paper
for any secularized interpretation of
anselm's moral theory
each of these can be explored by
reference to anselm's own thinking or
practice in these matters although for
reason of space i discuss only the first
set here
first there are some key concepts whose
adequate understanding on our part
requires retaining a theological
dimension or reference
second there are examples to be followed
and meditated upon which cannot be
adequately understood i think when
de-christianized
third for any given human person a
christian viewpoint will form an
integral part of requisite moral
self-understanding the understanding of
you know and judgment of one's
own condition fourth concepts and
doctrines drawn from christian moral
teachings will continue to be needed in
practical reasoning carried out
down to the level of particular cases
where action and concrete choice occurs
among many other examples which could be
provided of important moral concepts
worked out by anselm that would suffer
being essentially denatured by attempts
to strip away all theological elements
or references
three particularly interesting ones
would be the determinate forms of
justice in the will
the dis value involved in entirely
autonomous willing and the scope and
value of love
by rearticulating the essential nature
of justice as rectitude of will
maintained for its own sake anselm
introduces a risk of turning justice
into something contentless
merely formal and imperative to value
justice more highly than any other goods
offering
no substantive guidance about just what
such just volition would actually
involve
if one wants to reconstruct
what anselm actually thought to be the
things that one ought to will and the
reasons for which one ought to will
those things
you can glean and gather from his works
all sorts of rules reasonings
evaluations and orderings of goods
but when you do that you find out that
many of these presume coincide with and
even expand or illuminate a morality
stemming in part from classic
pre-christian sources but much more a
product of generations of christian
reflection practice and life
in addition anselm explicitly yokes
whose conception of rectitude of will
maintained for its own sake to the
divine will at numerous points in his
works
he tells us that keeping rectitude of
will for the sake of that very rectitude
is for each person
to will what god wills that person to
will
right maybe i should say that again
because that's one that always it's hard
to follow because there's so many wills
keeping rectitude of will for the sake
of that very rectitude so that's justice
is for each person to will what god
wills that person to will
this requires of human beings an effort
to learn to understand and discern what
it is that god wants them to will it
also bears implications for the way in
which we coordinate our own wills with
those of other people anselm tells us
for example those who fill their hearts
with love of god and neighbor
will will nothing but what god wills or
another person wills as long as this is
not contrary to god meaning another
person wants you to do wrong you're not
going to do that
this brings us to the second example
okay
actually maybe i'll i'll uh
skip to the uh the third example then
the nature and value of love provides a
third example of a distinctive christian
contribution to moral theory hansel
writes about love in so many places
elaborating so many themes as to provide
an embarrassment of citations but three
themes are enough to provide some sense
of the role
properly understood and lived out love
plays an anselm's moral vision he writes
about the the value the transaction the
permanency of love is a gift counseling
we should always strive to love more
than to be loved and to rejoice more
realizing that we gain more when we love
than when we are loved we ought not only
to do and to will justice he says but
even to love it
reason by which we understand rectitude
teaches that this rectitude is to be
kept out of love for the same rectitude
we ought to also direct our love towards
and into deeper and deeper relationships
with god as he tells us in the moment of
all jim he says the rational creature
ought to devote all of its capacities
and its will to loving the highest good
so this requires that the human being
should endeavor towards that good by
loving and desiring with its whole heart
soul and whole mind this raises up a
last and important point for this third
part once god has been granted a locus
in the moral landscape since god himself
is not only a good but a very great good
no moral theory that does not do justice
that good can really claim adequacy for
anselm as for any orthodox thinker god
is not merely a good among other goods
but the highest good the source of the
being and very goodness of goods so in
order to rightly understand in order to
more fully participate in justice
rectitude rationality goodness
human beings like it or not will have to
turn their minds to god
if they intend to do so fully they will
not only need to like this they will
have to cultivate love for this process
in practice and for its divine
collaborator the train of god
so on to the fourth part
for anselm we cannot really come to know
god our neighbor ourselves or fully
understand moral matters without
engagement in practical committed
christian living acting and willing as
an aside too even when we're doing that
quite often we screw it up he gives it
he shows all these letters where he's
giving advice
his own assessments of himself and his
prayers and meditations they show us
this
so
um god progressively reveals himself and
his will to us by collaborating in
remaking us into creatures sufficiently
receptive and attuned to the truth that
is continually offered to us this occurs
not only within the habit of a single
human being but also generationally
through through a broad ongoing
christian tradition and a community of
grace
so morality must be grounded on god in
yet another sense it must remain
actively grounded on god re-grounding
itself continuously in the acting
willing thinking person's ongoing
relation with god
and i'm just getting a little bit ahead
anselm talks about this in a number of
different texts so i'm going to set up
what are just going to be a few theses
and then hopefully explain one of them a
little bit
first there are revealing experiences or
more concretely matrices of experiences
volitional commitments and develop moral
dispositions
rightly reflected on and perseveringly
lived out which generate further needed
levels of understanding particularly in
matters of faith and morals
second anselm sets out elements of what
might be termed in ethics of the use of
the mind noting that a person's willing
choices about what thought to turn
attention to to occupy oneself with to
explore through contemplation or to
consent to bears fruits not only for
practice but also for discernment or use
of reason and for further direction of
the mind
third right conduct as well as
volitional and effective orientation
provides an index for proper
understanding and reasoning in moral
matters if we recognize ourselves going
wrong if we sense disharmonies in our
own will or between ours and the divine
will we know that the defect on our part
is not only volitional or practical but
also intellectual for anselm at least
fourth and finally as human beings
damaged in our being by the effects not
only of original sin but personal sins
imperfect in reason and in will we
require the aid and influx of divine
grace which anselm consistently depicts
as mercifully and bountifully given in
so many ways that anselm declines even
to exhaustively list the ways grace aids
a person to persevere in justice he says
not we can't even try to do that
in some cases this grace works through
the mediation of the saints or yet more
directly from god himself
in other cases in an anselm's view this
seems to be much more typically how
things go the grace offered a human
being occurs through divine human
interactions
he provides us a glimpse of the complex
structure of these workings in day
concordia among other places where he
writes of those who believe and practice
the faith but what i mean by divine
immune interactions is somebody else
who's human
is
collaborating with god to provide me who
needs it with grace
those who believe and practice the faith
is sowing cultivating seeds of right
thoughts and volitions in human hearts
which are then to produce further fruit
bearing further seeds so i can become a
conduit of grace for others yeah
and he says since what develops from
grace is a grace preaching hearing
understanding what has heard rectitude
of willing these are all instances of
graces
human collaboration with god takes place
precisely through the mediation and
contribution of other human
collaborators in many cases for handsome
um so if we cut ourselves off from that
you know we're
cutting ourselves off from that
what we need from grace so if i can
close with an aphorism
for anselm adequate morality is not only
a product of fide squibrin's intellectum
but yet more of razio at voluntas and
fides crescentes so growing in within
the faith
thanks
it's not perfectly clear nobody has any
questions right
it's the opposite
it's not perfectly clear
yeah can i ask for a comparative
assessment between between them
so it's safe you can answer them in
aquinas okay so so um
i i don't know so so i know some of you
this ants sell me into affection
psychology for the for justice and for
advantage through scotus i guess yeah
um but if i'm thinking about sort of the
adequacy of sort of thinking about that
kind of moral psychology right um and
contrasting it with a view like
aquinas's uh which you don't seem to
have this sort of double affection view
um in character and i wonder some you
know just just general reflections as a
question is whether or not you know
whether one has a good reason to sort of
follow be it a follower of ansel or be a
follower of aquinas with respect to um
the way we think about these kind of
psychologies i'm attracted to ansel's
view um but but it's tied in with the
larger matrix of
what else he's doing with that
um
and i don't know scott is well enough to
say whether scotus like you know
does something he shouldn't have done
with anselm's view i'm inclined to say
no since he's also a doctor of the
church but you know um so i myself i i
like
what is this view
it's that the will has
two fundamental inclinations things that
are constantly
driving us through through habits
through our desires
um
in sometimes in different directions and
they're not always opposed to each other
as a matter of fact one is the will to
happiness which is for for beneficial
goods
and
then that's okay but it if it's not um
kept in check by the will to justice
which also is the will to keep that very
well to justice
which in a certain way supervenes on and
orders
the the structure of the will to
happiness
um
then it's going to go awry
i i like that idea i like the idea
that
we choose
whether to
you know
keep what it is that we need to rightly
order things one of the things that i
i've been thinking a lot about where i
think anselm
might lead us off in the wrong direction
he looks at the world of justice almost
like an on switch off switch
in some of his treatises in others he
talks about it in much more nuanced ways
where a person can be more or less just
you know there is some still some
threshold where you made the wrong
choice you shouldn't have done that
will the justice is gone now the the
will to the the uh the will is affection
for the beneficial goods gonna lead you
off in all sorts of crazy stuff that you
shouldn't be doing and you could still
resist some of that he just says you
can't keep yourself from doing all of
the things that you shouldn't be doing
yeah i find that um
maybe i shouldn't but i find that
a compelling
view on things yeah
well where's that does it answer the
question i was asking for comparison
actually oh that's honestly so there's
right this view which so so sometimes i
hear people who are who are who are
attracted to you as you are yeah claim
that there's there's something um
superior about the spectral appliances
um
i've heard the notion that um that
instrument captures the fact that the
defection for justice requires the one
value of god in some sense
in in himself right in a way sort of
apart from the way that it serves one's
own happiness
um and the worry
and they claim against the thomas that
yeah you don't capture that with sort of
the single um sort of the single motive
single affection there could be cases
where it requires you to
will what god wants you to will more
than your own happiness but in many
cases for hansel it's actually
willing it's super beating on the world
of happiness in such ways to write the
order so it's more augustine in that
that respect can i just comment sure
yeah i've spent a long time but i i once
wrote a paper about scotus on effect so
steezy and hildebrand on objective value
and i asked
alan walter who's a scottish scholar
whether he thought affects her steezie
or wind up with hildebrand's objective
value
and uh
and choosing it for its own sake and he
said yes and there and then aquinas
you know people would say well value is
sort of always connected to
appetite for me yeah so so scotus and
anselm
have a real explicit opening to this
idea of
objective value like hilleberg would
call it and then thomas doesn't is what
they would say that's the right estimate
i don't think that thomas and anselm are
like too far off on these sort of things
though because for handsome
ultimately
you know keeping justice is something
that's good for you it is a beneficial
good he distinguishes three
actually not and not in the treatises so
much better than um day simultaneously
no it's in the dicta sorry he
distinguishes the good of being
good as komoda and then good as justice
which is only available for us
and the angels and those poor devils
that made the wrong choice
that don't get it anymore um
and so if i'm if i'm making
you know for i guess from our
perspective it often looks as if
i'm putting aside happiness i'm not
allowing myself to be motivated by
happiness by
you know making justice the central
thing but anselm sees them as integrated
with each other
i guess so far as we see them as
separated like that it would be a
reflection of what's wrong with us
you know
um
yeah
is that said
you had a question
is for ansel
is the relationship
is the way in
faith intersects with
morality
and epistemological
sort of thing that is we cannot reliably
or consistently know the good
so that faith helps us both reliably
know the good in individual instances
and consistently
know the good across a range of
instances
or
or is it both or different
is faith's role more
motivational that is it
so that
we have an epistemological problem
of knowing the good then we have the
the motivational problem of actually
consistently doing the good i mean
paul's romans 7 is pretty much a
motivational thing i know what i should
be doing but i'm not knowing it yeah
does and sound distinguish those clearly
is it he mix them up uh
well they are in practice those things
do
intersect with each other
and anselm will say things like when
he's considering in the day
the vertate
talks about a forced choice where
somebody tells you lie with free anthem
is always a bad thing you should never
lie for handsome
although weirdly enough you know certain
forms of deception are actually
okay you know in the in the uh the life
you know um certain highest deceptions
he says um anyway
the you should
you either lie or i'm gonna kill you
right
and lying is something you shouldn't do
it requires you to give up justice in
the will
and
he says if the person actually knew
what they were getting into it'd be a
lot easier for them to resist
the temptation to give in and tell a lie
in order to save their life
so faith can provide
both in some cases like that both an
epistemological and a
motivational contribution
um in some cases it will be more
epistemological
you know and i try to lay out different
modes in which this takes place
and in some cases it will be more
motivational
you know and some things we can't do
anything technically speaking
without relying on god's grace
and using what we've got so long as we
actually have justice in the will
it's because
we've managed to like hold on by our
fingernails and doing the right thing to
that thing that we got
thank god from god
and uh and we can lose it you know
and god is he says once we have justice
and the will
grace contributes
to to us helping us to overcome
temptations
there's always the possibility that we
can like
steer ourselves in the wrong direction
thereby we might lose so faith is
contributing in both ways
i would guess it probably works best
when it's
you know some sort of dynamic relation
time's up i think so all right well
thank you very much